Скільки місця нам потрібно для життя?
Апо Кан, який працює в берлінському театрі, вважає - небагато.
Він живе в конструкції "Маленький будиночок" на колесах.
Круто, коли щойно ти заходиш, опиняєшся у спальні, вітальні, кухні та коридорі - одразу скрізь.
Він так облаштований, що все можна за потреби,
так би мовити, розгорнути-згорнути - й отримати все, що потрібно.
Тут лише 9 квадратних метрів житлової площі.
Все необхідне ховається в підлозі, у стінах або у шухлядах.
Це приклад того, як - коли ви накуховарились, можна ось так сховати плиту.
До цієї базової концепції спочатку треба звикнути,
але зрештою розумієш, наскільки функціональна ця система - на всіх рівнях.
Жити у міні-будиночку - означає обмежити себе. Менше розкоші, менше речей.
Але для все більшої кількості людей – це альтернатива.
Міні-будиночки можуть також забезпечити міста новим доступним житлом.
Ось такі капсули можна було б встановити на землі, яка не використовується.
Або навіть на дахах будинків.
Знайти доступне житло у багатьох великих містах - вкрай важко.
Тому берлінський стартап пропонує побудувати місто на місті:
Міська інфраструктура сягає будинків до самих дахів.
І це те місце, до якого під'єднуються кабіни.
Дуже добре у містах те, що інфраструктура - всюдисуща.
У мене тут є підключення до електромережі, яке під'єднує мене до інтернету.
Схожим чином може бути облаштована і вода, і каналізація.
Міні-будиночки Cabin Spacey площею 20 квадратних метрів - доволі просторі.
Поки вони існують лише у вигляді макету, але вже зводиться перший прототип.
Коштуватиме будиночок 50 тисяч євро. І вже знайшлися 40 потенційних покупців.
Таким чином концепція і продукт дозволяють нам використати міський простір,
який не підходить для звичайного житла або просто лишився непоміченим.
Ми хотіли б використати будь-яку ділянку, достатню для того, щоб розмістити міні-будинок.
Лише в Берліні щорічна потреба в житлі складає 17 тисяч нових квартир,
тож ця ідея цілком може стати в нагоді.